Israeli soldiers examine the remains of
two rockets which struck here this
morning near the town of kiryat shmona
fired over the border from lebanon no
one was hurt and there was no damage but
of course people living nearby or
worried Israel responded immediately by
firing dozens of shells into Lebanese
territory Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu suggested Lebanon's
Hezbollah may have been behind the
attack but held the Beirut government
responsible we do not tolerate any
rocket fire and we respond forcefully if
necessary we take pre-emptive action we
hold the government of Lebanon
responsible for fire which comes from
its territory there's a history of
cross-border attacks in the area
Hezbollah launched numerous attacks on
Israel from here up to the 2006 Israel
Hezbollah war following the ceasefire
the situation has been mostly quiet but
the civil war raging in neighboring
Syria has spilled over the border with
Pro and anti Assad factions increasingly
active in Lebanon the funeral of
prominent Assad critic and former
finance minister Mohammed Atta is being
held in Beirut today he died in a bomb
attack on Friday via del it's a tragedy
for us in the whole country with all its
different factions because a great man
has been lost a moderate man a man with
the right word at the right time who
offered useful solutions for our country
other than fact that some analysts see
the death of shot on this morning's
rocket attacks on Israel as a sign that
the Lebanese government may be losing
control over what is happening in the
country